Welcome to another bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集奖励。
We are hard to work on season two, which we'll launch soon, and we want to use this space to share some appearances of the team on other great podcasts.
我们正在努力制作即将推出的第二季，我们希望利用这个空间来分享团队在其他精彩播客中的一些表现。
Today, we bring you Josh Radner's appearance on Life in Seven Songs.
今天，我们为您带来乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 在《七首歌中的人生》中的亮相。
On this podcast, they ask the question, what songs tell your story?
在这个播客上，他们问这样的问题：哪些歌曲讲述了你的故事？
They asked the question of some of the world's most fascinating people, and through seven songs, guests revealed the milestones and the music that have shaped their lives.
他们向世界上一些最迷人的人提出了问题，并通过七首歌，嘉宾们揭示了塑造他们生活的里程碑和音乐。
Take a listen now to Josh Radner's life in seven songs.
现在用七首歌来聆听乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的生活。
Ted was something I've described him as a younger brother, like he's not me, and he's sometimes annoying, but he's family.
泰德是我把他描述为弟弟的人，就像他不是我一样，他有时很烦人，但他是家人。
I feel like I can take him along now, and there's no problem.
我觉得我现在可以带他一起走，没有问题。
This is Life in Seven Songs.
这就是七歌人生。
From the San Francisco Standard, I'm Sophie Bareman.
我是旧金山标准报的索菲·巴雷曼。
Last week, I'm speaking with actor and musician Josh Ratner.
上周，我与演员兼音乐家乔什·拉特纳进行了交谈。
You might recognize him from shows like Grey's Anatomy, Six Feet Under, or Fleishman is in trouble.
您可能会在《实习医生格蕾》、《六尺之下》或《弗莱什曼有麻烦》等节目中认出他。
He's written and directed two feature films, starting countless plays on and off-Broadway.
他编写并导演了两部故事片，并在百老汇内外上演了无数的戏剧。
But he's best known for his longtime role as Ted Mosby, from the Emmy award-winning hit sitcom How I Met Your Mother.
但他最出名的是在艾美奖获奖情景喜剧《老爸老妈浪漫史》中长期扮演的泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Mosby) 角色。
A legacy he's been at war with for over the last decade.
过去十年来，他一直在与这个遗产作斗争。
Just recently, Josh has decided to stop trying to outrun Ted Mosby's shadow.
就在最近，乔什决定不再试图超越泰德·莫斯比的影子。
He's even launched a brand new rewatch podcast called how we made your mother These days Josh is embracing all the characters that live inside him.
他甚至推出了一个全新的重播播客，名为“我们如何创造了你的母亲”。这些天乔什正在拥抱生活在他内心的所有角色。
Josh Radner.
乔什·拉德纳。
Thanks for coming on the show Thanks for having me.
感谢您来到这个节目，感谢您邀请我。
It's good to be here.
很高兴来到这里。
I heard a little chuckle during that intro.
在介绍过程中我听到了一阵轻笑。
What were you reacting to?
你当时有什么反应？
Oh Stop being at war with Ted.
哦，别再和特德交战了。
I think that It's not inaccurate, but it made me laugh You played the role of Ted Mosby on how I met your mother for almost 10 years from 2005 to 2014.
我认为这并不不准确，但它让我笑了。从2005年到2014年，你在我如何认识你母亲的近10年里扮演了泰德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）的角色。
You've said it's given you a lot, but it's also taken some things from you as well.
你说它给了你很多，但它也从你身上夺走了一些东西。
Tell me about that.
告诉我这件事。
You know, it gave me some creative and financial freedom.
你知道，它给了我一些创作和财务上的自由。
It allowed me to become a musician.
它让我成为一名音乐家。
I don't know if I would have felt as emboldened to take these creative risks and do all these different things, but it also, it's strange from an identity perspective to be collapsed into a person.
我不知道我是否会感到有勇气去承担这些创造性的风险并做所有这些不同的事情，但从身份的角度来看，崩溃成一个人也是很奇怪的。
One of the reasons I wanted to be an actor was I wanted to kind of escape the prison of self.
我想成为一名演员的原因之一是我想逃离自我的牢笼。
You know, I wanted to live other lives and experiment.
你知道，我想过另一种生活并进行实验。
Like, what would it be like to not be me and step into these other shoes and have these experiences?
比如，如果不是我，穿上其他鞋子并拥有这些经历，会是什么样子？
But then you do something for that long.
但你会做那么长时间的事情。
Like, no actor really thinks like, I think for a decade, I'll be playing one role.
就像，没有一个演员真正认为，我想在十年内，我会扮演一个角色。
Like, it's a very, for me at least it gave me a kind of identity vertigo.
就像，这非常，至少对我来说，它给了我一种身份眩晕感。
I didn't like it when people refuse to let me be me or refuse to call me by my real name, like there was something very destabilizing about it.
我不喜欢人们拒绝让我做我自己，或者拒绝用我的真名来称呼我，就好像这里面有一些非常不稳定的东西。
Like when people would say, are you Ted Mosby?
就像人们会说，你是特德·莫斯比吗？
This might sound jerky, but I was a little like, I played him.
这听起来可能有点生涩，但我有点像，我扮演了他。
Like, I'm not him.
比如说，我不是他。
I played him and I was contractually obligated to say these lines and anything you loved or disliked about the character, please, like don't lay it at my feet like it wasn't, it wasn't me, you know.
我扮演他，根据合同，我有义务说出这些台词以及任何你喜欢或不喜欢这个角色的内容，请不要把它放在我脚下，就像它不是一样，这不是我，你知道的。
I mean, if you want to get to know me a little bit more, you should listen to my music and the film side directed because I generated those.
我的意思是，如果你想更多地了解我，你应该听听我的音乐和导演的电影，因为这些都是我创作的。
Those are the things I made.
这些是我做的东西。
This I was more of a hired gun.
我更像是一名雇佣兵。
It's like being defined by who you were in high school or something just frozen and not even right a layer removed because it's not even who you were.
这就像在高中时被定义为你是谁，或者只是冻结的东西，甚至没有被删除一层，因为它甚至不是你是谁。
Exactly but that thing of like people not wanting to honor where you are right now and wanting you to be a kind of thing where they got to know you and loved you or hated you whatever.
确切地说，就像人们不想尊重你现在所处的位置，而是希望你成为一种他们能够了解你、爱你或恨你的人。
Well you've mentioned briefly all the different parts yourself musician director and we we want to talk about all of that.
好吧，您已经简要提到了音乐家总监自己的所有不同部分，我们想讨论所有这些。
But first, I'm curious about you as a child.
但首先，我对小时候的你很好奇。
Well, I grew up in Columbus, Ohio.
嗯，我在俄亥俄州哥伦布长大。
I come from a Jewish family.
我来自一个犹太家庭。
I went to synagogue a lot of weekends, not every weekend.
我很多周末都去犹太教堂，但不是每个周末。
My parents were actively involved.
我的父母积极参与。
It was a very bookish house in terms of my parents.
对我父母来说，这是一座非常书卷气的房子。
Like my dad was on the board of the library.
就像我父亲是图书馆董事会成员一样。
That was kind of our big weekly field trip was like go to the library and get just tons of books.
这就是我们每周一次的大型实地考察，就像去图书馆获取大量书籍一样。
I wouldn't call it like a highly literary house.
我不会称其为高度文学性的房子。
It wasn't like we had to be reading Dickens around the fire or anything, it was just like, they wanted us to be readers.
这并不是说我们必须围着火堆读狄更斯的书，而是像他们希望我们成为读者一样。
So they really encouraged that.
所以他们确实鼓励这样做。
There was a lot of music in the house.
屋里有很多音乐。
My mom can sing, my dad cannot.
我妈妈会唱歌，我爸爸不会。
He can't really carry it in.
他实在带不进去。
Although I kind of like his voice in some strange way.
虽然我有点奇怪地喜欢他的声音。
But when I think about the music in my childhood home, there was vinyl, you know, we had a record player.
但当我想到我童年家里的音乐时，有黑胶唱片，你知道，我们有一台电唱机。
My parents years ago just dropped off the most incredible collection of vinyl at like a flea market or a thrift store or something without, and I was furious because it was like original Sergeant Pepper's original, so I'm in a Garfun.
几年前，我的父母刚刚在跳蚤市场或旧货店之类的地方扔下了最令人难以置信的黑胶唱片收藏，我很生气，因为它就像原始的佩珀中士的原版，所以我在加芬。
Like just, I still, it still bothers me, you know?
就像，我仍然，它仍然困扰着我，你知道吗？
Like how they just got rid of that collection.
就像他们刚刚处理掉那个收藏品一样。
Well, that's a perfect transition to your first song, which is one that was playing a lot in your childhood home.
嗯，这是到你的第一首歌的完美过渡，这首歌在你童年的家里经常播放。
Tell me about this one.
跟我说说这个吧。
There was a broad array of music going on in my house.
我家里正在播放各种各样的音乐。
There was a feeling of great 60s and 70s songwriters, Bob Dylan, Jim Croci was very big in our house, but my mom just always loved John Denver, you know, Annie's song and thank God I'm a country boy and Rocky Mountain High.
有一种 60 年代和 70 年代伟大词曲作家的感觉，鲍勃·迪伦 (Bob Dylan)、吉姆·克罗奇 (Jim Croci) 在我们家里非常重要，但我妈妈一直很喜欢约翰·丹佛 (John Denver)，你知道，安妮的歌，感谢上帝，我是一个乡村男孩，落基山高。
And I played all three of them to kind of like, figure out which one lights me up the most.
我玩了这三个游戏，想找出哪一个最让我兴奋。
And for some reason, Rocky Mountain High felt like, I just like where it goes.
出于某种原因，落基山高感觉就像，我只是喜欢它去的地方。
It's like a very simple song, but it also feels like you can feel the outside.
这就像一首非常简单的歌曲，但也让人感觉可以感受到外面的一切。
Like it almost feels like it was recorded on a mountain or something like you can feel the spaciousness in it.
感觉就像是在山上录制的，或者你可以感受到其中的宽敞。
Next on your list is Respect by Aretha Franklin.
名单上的下一个是艾瑞莎·富兰克林的《尊重》。
And funny enough, this song is associated with the kind of coming of age story for you.
有趣的是，这首歌与你的成长故事有关。
Can you tell me that story?
你能告诉我那个故事吗？
Well, first of all, I just, I think it's maybe like the best song ever written.
嗯，首先，我只是，我认为这可能是有史以来最好的歌曲。
It's impossible, I think, to hear that song and not have your spirit lifted.
我想，听到这首歌而不会让你精神振奋是不可能的。
like her voice, the urgency of it, the demand of it.
就像她的声音，它的紧迫性，它的要求。
I just find it to be a thrilling song.
我只是觉得这是一首激动人心的歌曲。
But it was a song that my older sister and I, Melanie, we just both really loved the song.
但这是我姐姐和我梅兰妮都非常喜欢的一首歌。
And I was a competitive swimmer when I was young, all my sisters and I were.
我年轻时是一名竞技游泳运动员，我和我所有的姐妹都是。
And we were at the Maccabee youth games, which is kind of like the Jewish kid Olympics, which is not, you know, it's not like real Olympics.
我们参加了马卡比青年运动会，这有点像犹太儿童奥运会，但你知道，这不像真正的奥运会。
It was like Jewish kid Olympics.
这就像犹太儿童奥运会。
And I must have been in like sixth great or something.
我一定是第六名之类的。
And I really, I had such eyes for this gymnast from Los Angeles.
我真的，我对这位来自洛杉矶的体操运动员非常有眼光。
And one night we ended up kind of talking alone.
有一天晚上，我们就这样单独聊天了。
And we had what I think was a kiss, but it might have been like a half kiss.
我认为我们是一个吻，但也可能像是一个半吻。
It might have been like a hug where my lips caught the edge of her lips.
这可能就像一个拥抱，我的嘴唇碰到了她的嘴唇边缘。
And I went back to the dorm.
然后我就回宿舍了。
And for some reason on my way back, I just started singing that song to myself because it felt like a celebratory moment.
出于某种原因，在回来的路上，我开始给自己唱那首歌，因为这感觉像是一个庆祝的时刻。
And when I got back there, I guess Melanie, my sister and some of her friends had seen me with her or knew that I had peeled off with her and they asked me what happened and all I did was sing this song with this big stupid grin on my face.
当我回到那里时，我猜梅兰妮、我姐姐和她的一些朋友看到我和她在一起，或者知道我和她分手了，他们问我发生了什么事，我所做的就是唱着这首歌，脸上挂着大大的愚蠢的笑容。
You know, when you're that age, the idea that your lips would get close to another girl's lips is just astonishing.
你知道，当你到了那个年纪，你的嘴唇会靠近另一个女孩的嘴唇的想法真是令人惊讶。
But for some reason, I always associate that with my first almost kiss.
但出于某种原因，我总是将其与我的初吻联系在一起。
I think I got closer than I'd ever gotten before and that was the song that got emblazoned in my mind from it.
我想我比以前更接近了，这就是我脑海中铭记的那首歌。
I just thought of something listening to that.
我只是想到了一些听着的东西。
There's something about her voice that is so ragged and raw and full of experience and somewhat exhaustion but like indomitable spirit like that's what I hear in when she sings and there's something so funny about me appropriating that as like a sixth grader using that as the song when I am, I couldn't have been more innocent and lacking in experience but it's kind of like there was something about that song I just kind of took as like my initiatory song into some other world.
她的声音里有一种粗糙、原始、充满经验和有点疲惫的感觉，但就像我在她唱歌时听到的那样，有一种不屈不挠的精神，而我把这首歌当作六年级学生使用的歌曲，这很有趣，我再天真了，也缺乏经验，但这有点像我把那首歌当作我进入另一个世界的入门歌曲。
do you know where that girl is today?
你知道那个女孩今天在哪里吗？
I don't.
我不知道。
But she was an incredible gymnast.
但她是一位令人难以置信的体操运动员。
I do remember that.
我确实记得这一点。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
I also love this image of your sister just seeing that goofy smile on your face that like knowing.
我也喜欢你姐姐的这张照片，只是看到你脸上傻乎乎的微笑，就像知道一样。
Right.
正确的。
And we were we were now like best friends, but we were pretty adversarial at that point.
我们现在就像最好的朋友，但那时我们非常敌对。
And I think there was something about my goofiness and my irrepressible happiness that sawed something between us maybe.
我认为我的愚蠢和我无法抑制的幸福也许在我们之间带来了一些东西。
So far you've described pretty easy going childhood.
到目前为止，你已经描述了相当轻松的童年。
I think I read maybe in your sub stack some mention of tougher moments in childhood, like things where you felt misunderstood.
我想我可能在你的子堆栈中读到了一些童年时期艰难时刻的提及，比如你感到被误解的事情。
Can you elaborate on that a little bit?
您能详细说明一下吗？
It was a relatively stable childhood, but I've also, as I look back and consider maybe having a family of my own, you're always kind of looking at your parents going, Well, I'm going to take this, but I'm letting this go, you know, my parents in each of their own ways had some tough things in their childhood and they were, they wanted us to have like a happy house.
那是一个相对稳定的童年，但当我回顾过去并考虑是否拥有自己的家庭时，你总是会看着你的父母说，好吧，我会接受这个，但我会放手，你知道，我的父母在他们的童年里以各自的方式经历了一些艰难的事情，他们希望我们有一个幸福的家。
But in some ways they banished some of the darker things like anger wasn't quite permitted.
但在某些方面，他们消除了一些更黑暗的东西，比如愤怒是不被允许的。
They didn't want you to be sad for that long.
他们不想让你悲伤那么久。
You know, I have a joke that when my parents said we just want you to be happy, what they really meant was we just want you to be happy.
你知道，我有一个笑话，当我的父母说我们只是希望你快乐时，他们真正的意思是我们只是希望你快乐。
like they really wanted you to not linger too long.
就像他们真的希望你不要逗留太久一样。
So I had to kind of go out and get some remedial work in feeling things.
所以我必须出去做一些补救工作来感受事物。
One of the reasons I think I was attracted to acting in the theatre was it allowed me to experience emotions that I couldn't quite experience in my childhood home, but that were, I was applauded, you know, in a fictional context.
我认为我被剧院表演所吸引的原因之一是它让我体验到了我在童年家里无法体验到的情感，但那就是，我在虚构的背景下受到了掌声。
Like there wasn't allowed a lot of screaming in my childhood home.
就像我童年的家里不允许有太多尖叫一样。
But if I did a David Mamet play and had to scream, everyone stood up and cheered.
但如果我演大卫·马梅的戏剧而不得不尖叫，每个人都会站起来欢呼。
Were you like a theater kid, you know, in quotes?
你知道，你像一个戏剧小孩吗？
I wasn't, but my friend Debbie Schell, who was in my grade, really wanted to audition for the chorus of Oklahoma, so she asked me to come sit with her and keep her company because she was nervous.
我不是，但我的朋友黛比·谢尔（Debbie Schell）与我同年级，她真的很想参加俄克拉荷马州合唱团的试镜，所以她让我和她坐在一起并陪伴她，因为她很紧张。
So I was sitting in the auditorium, and I was watching all these people get up and sing a couple bars of a song and read some scenes.
所以我坐在礼堂里，看着所有这些人站起来唱几小节歌曲并朗读一些场景。
And something in me said, I think I could do this just as well, if not better than these people.
我心里的某个声音说，我想我也能做到这一点，即使不能比这些人更好。
And then the director or the choreographer pointed at me, said, are you going to audition?
然后导演或者编舞指着我说，你去试镜吗？
And the next thing I knew I was on stage, and I was reading.
接下来我知道我在舞台上，我正在读书。
And then I got one of the leads in Oklahoma, this part Will Parker, this great part.
然后我在俄克拉荷马州找到了一位主角，威尔·帕克这个角色，这个很棒的角色。
And my sister got this other great part, Anne Eller.
我姐姐得到了另一个重要的角色，安妮·埃勒。
But she was like, this little jerk, my little jerk brother just stumbles in and gets one of the leads.
但她就像，这个小混蛋，我的小混蛋兄弟只是偶然闯入并获得了线索之一。
And I had to work my way up.
我必须努力向上。
But there's this moment where Anne Eller and Will, he picks her up and off a barrel of hay and starts dancing with her.
但就在这个时刻，安妮·埃勒和威尔，他把她从干草桶上抱起来，开始和她跳舞。
And so when I picked my sister up and we started dancing around the stage, the whole school erupted in tears because they knew we were brother and sister and they thought it was really funny.
因此，当我抱起姐姐并开始在舞台上跳舞时，整个学校都泪流满面，因为他们知道我们是兄妹，他们认为这真的很有趣。
I remember it as a watershed moment, like, oh, they know who I am.
我记得这是一个分水岭，就像，哦，他们知道我是谁。
They know who my sister is.
他们知道我妹妹是谁。
They know we're brother and sister and I felt really seen in a really nice way.
他们知道我们是兄弟姐妹，我感觉自己受到了很好的对待。
So that was your first foray into acting and you continue to act in school.
所以那是你第一次涉足演艺事业，并且你继续在学校表演。
And I was surprised to read that your school I actually did a production of Cabaret, which is quite risque, and you got the role of the MC, which is a huge role.
我很惊讶地发现你们学校我实际上制作了歌舞表演，这是相当有伤风化的，而你得到了MC的角色，这是一个巨大的角色。
Why was that role so formative for you?
为什么这个角色对你如此重要？
Something about that role lit something up in me and turned some light on inside me that said, oh, I want to keep doing this.
这个角色的某些东西点燃了我内心的某些东西，并在我内心打开了一些光芒，告诉我，哦，我想继续这样做。
I want to keep doing this.
我想继续这样做。
And I took out the CD from the Vexley Library, and whenever my house was empty, I had like a rehearsal cane and I was just like a 16 year old madman, like just dancing around the house, singing at the top of my lungs, like figuring out how my body worked in this kind of show busy way.
我从韦克斯利图书馆拿出CD，每当我的房子空着的时候，我就像排练手杖一样，就像一个16岁的疯子，就像在房子里跳舞，用尽全力唱歌，就像在这种忙碌的方式中弄清楚我的身体是如何运作的。
And my whole performance was basically just a rip off of Joel Gray.
我的整个表演基本上就是抄袭乔尔·格雷。
I don't know that I did anything all that original, but I did the opening song called Villekommen, where the MC welcomes the audience, the fake audience in the Kit Kat Club and the real audience sitting in the theater.
我不知道我做了什么原创的事情，但我做了开场曲《Villekommen》，其中主持人欢迎观众、Kit Kat 俱乐部的假观众和坐在剧院的真正观众。
It's one of the great opening numbers in any musical, I think.
我认为这是任何音乐剧中最精彩的开场曲目之一。
There's a sinister undertone to it because it promises lightness and not a care in the world but underneath is this encroaching fascism.
它有一种险恶的基调，因为它承诺轻松，而不是对世界的关心，但其背后却是法西斯主义的侵蚀。
When I think about doing that play all those years ago, this is the song that for some reason looms largest.
当我想起多年前的那出戏时，出于某种原因，这首歌是最重要的。
Do you remember any of the words or lyrics off the top of your head?
您还记得脑海中浮现的任何单词或歌词吗？
Sure.
当然。
come and be a new welcome.
来吧，成为新的欢迎者。
My guidance counselor, she came up to me after the Saturday show and And she said, you need to see me first thing in the morning on Monday.
我的指导顾问，周六演出结束后她来找我，她说，你周一早上第一件事就是要见我。
So I came in before Homeroom who were sitting there and she said, I'm going to say something to you and I really wanted to hear me.
所以我来到坐在那里的班主任面前，她说，我要对你说一些话，我真的很想听我说。
And she said, you are never to stop acting.
她说，你永远不能停止表演。
Wow.
哇。
And even if you become a lawyer, I want you to do community theater.
即使你成为一名律师，我也希望你去社区剧院。
Will you promise me you're never going to stop?
你能向我保证你永远不会停止吗？
And I said, okay.
我说，好吧。
And she died very tragically about a year later.
大约一年后，她悲惨地去世了。
And I think about her a lot because I yeeted her advice, you know, I never stopped.
我经常想起她，因为我听取了她的建议，你知道，我从未停止过。
How did your parents feel about you getting more and more into theater?
你的父母对你越来越喜欢戏剧有什么看法？
I think they knew that I was lit up by it and they knew I wanted to do more of it.
我想他们知道我被它照亮了，他们知道我想做更多。
And then when I was applying to college, my dad's only rule was he said, you got to get a liberal arts education.
然后当我申请大学时，我父亲唯一的规则是他说，你必须接受文科教育。
I don't want you just studying theater.
我不希望你只学习戏剧。
I don't want you to get a BFA.
我不想让你获得学士学位。
And I ended up going to the school Kenyan college where he actually went.
我最终去了他实际上就读的肯尼亚大学。
But they happened to have a really great theater department.
但他们碰巧有一个非常棒的戏剧系。
Paul Newman went there.
保罗·纽曼去了那里。
and Janney went there like so I kind of got to please my father while also charting my own course in this thing that I was really drawn to and midway or towards the end of my sophomore year I declared a drama major.
珍妮去了那里，这样我就可以取悦我的父亲，同时也为我真正感兴趣的这件事制定了自己的路线，在我大二的中途或接近尾声的时候，我宣布主修戏剧。
And by that point parents were okay with it?
到那时父母就同意了吗？
No I wouldn't say that.
不，我不会这么说。
I mean I think my mom was quietly in my corner.
我的意思是我认为我妈妈静静地在我的角落里。
It was an ongoing protracted negotiation with my dad especially.
尤其是与我父亲的谈判持续了很长时间。
I think he just kept realizing, like, oh, he's taking this incredibly seriously.
我想他只是不断意识到，哦，他非常认真地对待这件事。
This is not a hobby he's flirting with and is going to lose interest in.
这不是他正在调情并且会失去兴趣的爱好。
What does your dad have to say now?
你爸爸现在有什么要说的吗？
You know, my dad said something to me years ago that was really meaningful to me.
你知道，我父亲几年前对我说了一些对我来说非常有意义的事情。
He said, we're different.
他说，我们不一样。
Like, you're an artist.
就像，你是一位艺术家。
You know, my dad's actually he's artistic.
你知道，我爸爸其实很有艺术天赋。
He's a great sculptor.
他是一位伟大的雕塑家。
But I don't think he'd call himself an artist like in his bloodstream or DNA.
但我不认为他会像他的血液或 DNA 那样称自己为艺术家。
I think he recognizes that I'm an artist and I was going to be miserable if I didn't live a creative life and there was something very meaningful about that to me because it I think I was always worried that he was alarmed that I didn't choose his life but he's thrilled he knows that for me I made the right choice and it wouldn't have been the right choice for him but for me it was and I think he he's really pleased.
我认为他认识到我是一名艺术家，如果我没有过上创造性的生活，我会很痛苦，这对我来说是非常有意义的，因为我认为我总是担心他会因为我没有选择他的生活而感到震惊，但他很高兴他知道对我来说我做出了正确的选择，这对他来说不是正确的选择，但对我来说这是正确的选择，我认为他真的很高兴。
Your next song is tied to those college years it's all I want from Joni Mitchell's album Blue yeah so tell me why you picked this particular song?
你的下一首歌与那些大学时光有关，这就是我想要的乔尼·米切尔的专辑《蓝色是的》，所以告诉我你为什么选择这首特别的歌曲？
I remember my senior year.
我记得我高三那年。
It was one of those albums that got so entirely under my skin.
这是一张让我非常不舒服的专辑。
It felt like I was constitutionally incapable of not hearing it.
感觉就像我天生无法听不到它一样。
So I carried the CD around with me, and whoever was the room I was in, I would demand that they play the album.
所以我随身带着这张CD，无论我在哪个房间，我都会要求他们播放这张专辑。
Luckily, it's genius.
幸运的是，这是天才。
And it's always stayed with me as like an all-timer, that album.
那张专辑就像史上最经典的专辑一样一直陪伴着我。
I chose the first track, All I Want, which is just a song I adore.
我选择了第一首歌曲《All I Want》，这是一首我喜欢的歌曲。
but it feels like my senior year of college to me.
但这对我来说就像大学四年级。
I am a lonely road and traveling, traveling, traveling, traveling, looking for something, what can it be?
我在孤独的路上旅行，旅行，旅行，旅行，寻找什么，那会是什么呢？
Oh, I hate you some, I hate you some, I love you some.
哦，我有些恨你，有些恨你，有些爱你。
I just love the idea of I hate you some, I hate you some, I love you some.
我只是喜欢这样的想法：我恨你一些，我恨你一些，我爱你一些。
Even the line about like, I want to shampoo you.
甚至还有类似“我想给你洗头”之类的台词。
The whole thing felt like, What?
整件事的感觉就像是，什么？
Like just insanely cool, just like being invited into the VIP section of human emotion.
简直太酷了，就像被邀请进入人类情感的 VIP 部分一样。
That's the perfect song for being on this precipice of so much change.
对于处于如此巨大变化的悬崖边来说，这是一首完美的歌曲。
Yeah, I was very scared of adulthood.
是的，我非常害怕成年。
I was very scared of what do I do without a dining hall?
我很害怕没有食堂我该怎么办？
What do I do without all my friends on this little hilltop in Ohio?
在俄亥俄州的这个小山顶上，没有我所有的朋友，我该怎么办？
And I think Joni Mitchell was saying something that felt more complicated.
我认为乔尼·米切尔所说的事情感觉更复杂。
That album, it felt like a kind of Rosetta Stone about adulthood, like a sneak peek at what adulthood might feel like, that there was something like scary and heartbreaking and triumphant and fun.
这张专辑感觉就像是关于成年的罗塞塔石碑，就像一睹成年的感觉，有一些可怕的、令人心碎的、胜利的、有趣的东西。
It's time for a quick break.
是时候快速休息一下了。
When we come back, Josh heads into the real world of acting with all of its highs and lows.
当我们回来时，乔什进入了现实的表演世界，经历了所有的高潮和低谷。
Stay with us.
留在我们身边。
So eventually you graduate and go on to study theater at NYU, but what happens after that?
所以最终你毕业并继续在纽约大学学习戏剧，但之后会发生什么？
I imagine you start auditioning.
我想你开始试镜了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I always found something disheartening about walking into an audition room and there's just like 12 guys dressed the same as you, same hair color, same build.
当我走进试镜室时，我总觉得有一些令人沮丧的事情，那里大约有 12 个和你穿着一样、发色、体型一样的人。
And you think like, I just never liked that feeling of being fungible or just like one of many.
你会想，我只是从来不喜欢那种可替代的感觉，或者只是像许多人中的一员一样。
I think that was impetus to distinguish myself.
我认为这是让我脱颖而出的动力。
You know, I didn't want to give up, But I needed to get through that period where I felt like just another actor, like I really worked hard.
你知道，我不想放弃，但我需要度过那段时期，在那里我感觉自己只是另一个演员，就像我真的很努力一样。
You'd get close to things, you'd have some humiliating auditions where you were like, I can't believe that's the best I had that day.
你会接近事物，你会进行一些令人羞辱的试镜，你会说，我不敢相信这是我那天最好的成绩。
And also there's a lot of heartbreak because some things you really want, you don't get.
而且还有很多令人心碎的事情，因为有些东西你真正想要的却没有得到。
I think a lot of actors like no matter what your theology, you end up having somewhat of a spiritual belief around it because you realize the roles that are yours you're going to get and the roles that aren't yours, you're not going to get and you just have have to make peace with that.
我认为很多演员都喜欢，无论你的神学是什么，你最终都会有某种精神信仰，因为你意识到你将获得的角色是你的，而不是你的角色，你不会得到，你只需要接受这一点。
Did you choose any music for this era of your life?
您为您人生的这个时期选择过什么音乐吗？
Yeah, actually.
是的，实际上。
So this would be late 20s.
所以这将是20多岁。
This is pre how I met your mother.
这是我认识你母亲之前的事。
Like this is kind of on the doorstep of how I met your mother.
就像这就是我遇见你母亲的家门口。
I had my first very serious relationship in my 20s with an actress who I'm still friends with.
我在 20 多岁的时候与一位女演员建立了第一次非常认真的关系，我现在仍然是朋友。
She's lovely.
她很可爱。
But we were together for about three years.
但我们在一起大约三年了。
We had gone back and forth between New York and Ella.
我们在纽约和埃拉之间来回穿梭。
She's the one who really introduced me to Los Angeles.
她是真正把我介绍给洛杉矶的人。
And at the time on KCRW, the NPR outlet out in Los Angeles, there was a great morning program called Morning Becomes a Collectic hosted by this guy Nick Harcourt.
当时，在洛杉矶的 NPR 媒体 KCRW 上，有一个很棒的早间节目，名为“Morning Getting a Collectic”，由尼克·哈考特 (Nick Harcourt) 主持。
And he would have these incredible live sets in the 11 o'clock hour of any artists or bands coming through town.
他会在 11 点钟的任何艺术家或乐队进城时进行这些令人难以置信的现场表演。
And I heard Damien Rice do a live set.
我还听到达米安·赖斯 (Damien Rice) 进行了现场表演。
That was maybe in the early spring.
那可能是在早春的时候。
But then we broke up and I went back to New York.
但后来我们分手了，我回到了纽约。
And I went into like a bit of a depression and I found the import of Damien Rice's Oh, this album that was not available in the States yet.
我陷入了一点沮丧，我发现了达米安·赖斯（Damien Rice）的《Oh，这张专辑》的重要性，这张专辑在美国还没有发行。
It was something like $38 at Virgin Megastore on Union Square, like it was like really expensive at the time.
联合广场维珍大卖场的售价约为 38 美元，当时看来真的很贵。
But I bought it and for some reason the opening track Delicate is the one I probably returned to the most and I actually really like playing it myself.
但我买了它，出于某种原因，开场曲《Delicate》可能是我最常听的一首，而且我真的很喜欢自己演奏它。
It's just a really simple but a heartbreaking opener.
这只是一个非常简单但却令人心碎的开场白。
How would you listen to that album like walking around or?
你会如何听这张专辑，比如四处走动或？
Yeah, I'd listen to it walking around.
是的，我会听它四处走动。
I mean, I had it on all the time, like truly all the time.
我的意思是，我一直戴着它，真的一直戴着它。
And I also had like a first-generation iPod.
我还有第一代 iPod。
So I have very strong memories of walking around New York City, walking by the river.
所以我对在纽约市散步、在河边散步有着非常深刻的记忆。
And it was just like Joni Mitchell.
就像乔尼·米切尔一样。
It was just the only music I could bear listening to.
这是我唯一能忍受听的音乐。
And I listened to this music so much.
我听了很多这种音乐。
I would approach anyone on the street and be like, you got to hear this, like I was, I became an evangelist for this record.
我会接近街上的任何人，然后说，你必须听到这个，就像我一样，我成为了这张唱片的传播者。
I just thought it was the most beautiful thing I'd ever heard.
我只是觉得这是我听过的最美丽的事情。
And I was also going through my first legitimate heartbreak.
我也经历了第一次真正的心碎。
So it was, it was kind of, it was sound tracking my life in a sentimental and possibly annoying way.
所以它是，它是一种，它以一种感伤且可能令人讨厌的方式跟踪我的生活。
But for the time, at least I needed it.
但就目前而言，至少我需要它。
So you mentioned that that music is kind of on the precipice of high met your mother.
所以你提到音乐有点像在悬崖边遇见你的母亲。
So let's go there.
那么我们就去那里吧。
Huge role did a lot for your career, of course.
当然，巨大的角色对你的职业生涯有很大帮助。
I've talked quite a bit about this, but I think that the first two seasons of how I met your mother were incredibly destabilizing and strange.
我已经谈了很多这个问题，但我认为我遇见你母亲的前两季是令人难以置信的不稳定和奇怪的。
And I was excited that all this stuff was happening, but I also had some imposter syndrome.
我很兴奋所有这些事情的发生，但我也有一些冒名顶替综合症。
And beyond that, I was uncomfortable with the erosion of my anonymity.
除此之外，我对自己的匿名性受到侵蚀感到不安。
The rest of the cast was a little more acclimated to it.
其他演员对此更加适应了一些。
A lot of them had had big shows on before, but this was really my first experience with that.
他们中的很多人以前都举办过大型演出，但这确实是我第一次经历。
So I was really looking for something that felt very meaningful and deep and it had nothing to do with show business or Hollywood or television.
所以我真的在寻找一些感觉非常有意义和深刻的东西，它与演艺界、好莱坞或电视无关。
And I ended up through a series of twists and turns going to South America a bunch and starting to work with Iowaska, which is this, you know, plant medicine teacher liquid thing, which a lot of people probably know about it now.
我最终经历了一系列的曲折，去了南美洲，并开始与爱荷华州合作，这就是植物医学老师液体的东西，现在很多人可能都知道了。
But this This was 2007, so this was early.
但这是2007年，所以现在还早。
And I ended up kind of pairing how I met your mother with this psychedelic journey that I was on in my 30s.
我最终将我与你母亲的相遇与我 30 多岁时的迷幻之旅联系起来。
I wasn't, I was never like a druggy person.
我不是，我从来都不像一个吸毒的人。
You know, I did mushrooms once or twice in my 20s and had really powerful experiences with it, but I was trying to get into an almost like bigger cosmic space than just show business which was starting to feel claustrophobic.
你知道，我在 20 多岁的时候做过一两次蘑菇，并且拥有非常强大的经验，但我试图进入一个几乎更大的宇宙空间，而不仅仅是演艺界，这开始让人感到幽闭恐惧症。
So I did a lot of ayahuasca while I was on how I met your mother.
所以当我在讲述我是如何遇见你母亲的时候，我喝了很多死藤水。
And it was a very strange, but also like balancing act for me.
这对我来说是一种非常奇怪但又像是平衡的行为。
Like it actually helped me stay centered and not be so rocked by the currents of fame and visibility and who's up, who's down like all that nonsense.
就像它实际上帮助我保持中心地位，而不是被名气和知名度的潮流以及谁上升，谁下降等所有这些废话所震撼。
That was really hard for my ego to bear at least.
至少我的自尊心确实难以承受。
The first time that I re-engaged with psychedelics was in Santa Cruz with some friends from this community.
我第一次重新接触迷幻药是在圣克鲁斯，和这个社区的一些朋友一起。
And we did two nights of mushroom ceremonies.
我们举行了两晚的蘑菇仪式。
My friend John made this incredible playlist.
我的朋友约翰制作了这个令人难以置信的播放列表。
And I think I had actually turned him onto this song.
我想我实际上已经让他喜欢上了这首歌。
There's an album of songs about Tara, who's a Buddhist goddess.
有一张关于佛教女神度母的歌曲专辑。
And the final song is this gorgeous song.
最后一首歌是这首美妙的歌曲。
It's just called Tara.
它只是叫塔拉。
That song came on kind of towards the end of one of these journeys, but it wasn't like the end.
这首歌是在其中一次旅程即将结束时响起的，但这并不像结束。
The medicine was really strong and it was really beautiful.
药力确实很强，而且也确实很漂亮。
But I remember dancing around to this song I had this image of myself in front of people sharing songs that felt very real.
但我记得随着这首歌跳舞，我在人们面前分享了感觉非常真实的歌曲。
It felt like half prophetic or something like you can do this, like you can write songs, you can play them in front of people.
感觉就像半预言或者类似你可以做到这一点，就像你可以写歌，你可以在人们面前演奏它们。
And this song has a, it's kind of a three act structure and it's very long.
这首歌有一种三幕结构，而且很长。
So if you can sit with it and listen to it all the way through, it starts very slow and And it erupts in the third act into something I think is really thrilling and triumphant.
因此，如果你能坐在一起并从头到尾听它，它开始时非常缓慢，并且在第三幕中爆发成我认为真正令人兴奋和胜利的东西。
And it's just an important song to me.
这对我来说只是一首重要的歌曲。
This is Tara by, I might butcher the name.
这是塔拉，我可能会毁掉这个名字。
I don't know how to pronounce it either.
我也不知道怎么发音。
Great.
伟大的。
Dutch and Shaq, Dagsay.
达奇和沙克、达格赛。
Well, I'll look into that.
嗯，我会调查一下。
and Shaq Dagsay, I think, is good.
我认为沙克·达格赛（Shaq Dagsay）很好。
Does it just take you right back to dancing and Santa Cruz?
它会让你回到跳舞和圣克鲁斯吗？
It totally does, yeah, yeah.
确实如此，是啊，是啊。
It was quite profound.
这是相当深刻的。
It's hard to explain.
这很难解释。
I've never really told that story publicly because it, I sometimes feel like talking about something that happens on psychedelics is a little like talking about what happened in a dream and it's really most interesting to you.
我从来没有真正公开讲过这个故事，因为有时我觉得谈论迷幻药上发生的事情有点像谈论梦中发生的事情，这对你来说真的是最有趣的。
but it was profound for me and I was attracted to meditation and psychedelics I think because I wanted to touch those parts of me that were more patient and more spacious and more capable of love and intimacy all of which I think scared me as a young man but I did a lot of work because I knew that a life without those things would have felt impoverished.
但这对我来说意义深远，我被冥想和迷幻剂所吸引，我想是因为我想触摸我内心那些更有耐心、更宽敞、更有能力爱和亲密的部分，所有这些我认为作为一个年轻人让我感到害怕，但我做了很多工作，因为我知道没有这些东西的生活会感到贫困。
So you had this kind of of psychedelic vision of yourself performing music for people, which you're doing now.
所以你对自己为人们表演音乐有一种迷幻的愿景，而你现在正在这样做。
But how did you first start pursuing music after that experience?
但在那次经历之后你是如何开始追求音乐的呢？
Yeah, so interesting.
是啊，太有趣了。
I don't know that I would have been a musician without how I met your mother because one day one of the co-creators of the show said, do you know the musician Ben Lee?
我不知道如果没有遇见你母亲我会成为一名音乐家，因为有一天该节目的联合创作者之一说，你认识音乐家本·李吗？
And I said, yeah, yeah, I like him a lot.
我说，是的，是的，我非常喜欢他。
I think his music is great.
我认为他的音乐很棒。
And he said, he's coming to set.
他说，他要来片场。
So I got very excited.
所以我非常兴奋。
I was like the musical guy on set.
我就像片场的音乐人。
Like I was always making playlists for everyone and CDs and stuff.
就像我总是为每个人制作播放列表和 CD 之类的东西。
So Ben and I connected.
于是我和本建立了联系。
And I remember we just stayed after we were done shooting.
我记得我们拍完后就留下来了。
We just stayed and talked for a really long time.
我们只是留下来聊了很长时间。
And we just were friends for about a decade.
我们只是做了大约十年的朋友。
He liked my writing and he said, I think you'd be a great lyricist and let's write a song.
他喜欢我的作品，他说，我认为你会成为一名出色的作词家，我们来写一首歌吧。
And he taught me all about song structure and chord voicings and rhythm and lyric writing.
他教了我所有关于歌曲结构、和弦、节奏和歌词写作的知识。
We toured a ton and I was really thrown into the fire.
我们巡演了很多次，我真的被扔进了火里。
And it was such a thrill because I was such a music fan but I thought songwriting was some weird superpower and I thought you had to start when you were super young I thought you had to have a band in your parent's garage when you were 15 or you were a legitimate musician, but I just really love storytelling, but I love telling a story atop beautiful music.
这太令人兴奋了，因为我是个音乐迷，但我认为歌曲创作是一种奇怪的超能力，我认为你必须在非常年轻的时候就开始我认为你必须在 15 岁的时候在你父母的车库里拥有一支乐队，或者你是一个合法的音乐家，但我真的很喜欢讲故事，但我喜欢在美丽的音乐上讲述一个故事。
I still think of it as storytelling.
我仍然认为这是讲故事。
It's just like a three-minute story or a four-minute story versus a 90-minute story or a nine-year story.
这就像一个三分钟的故事或一个四分钟的故事与一个90分钟的故事或一个九年的故事。
I guess as we're talking about all this, a bigger question that comes to mind is what are you trying to say with your music?
我想当我们谈论这一切时，我想到的一个更大的问题是你想用你的音乐表达什么？
I don't know that I have an overarching message.
我不知道我有一个重要的信息。
I mean, I guess if I was to take a swing at it, you know, I have a song of my first record, first volume of eulogy, called Joshua 45-46, and it's about me turning 46 years old.
我的意思是，我想如果我要尝试一下的话，你知道，我的第一张专辑中有一首歌曲，第一卷悼词，叫做约书亚 45-46，它是关于我 46 岁的。
And I say, I started writing songs when I was just north of 40.
我说，我在 40 岁左右的时候就开始写歌了。
I try to write some every day.
我尝试每天写一些。
I wish that I had started sometime in the 90s, but I'm not sure I have much to say.
我希望我是在 90 年代的某个时候开始的，但我不确定我有什么可说的。
It used to drive me crazy when older people, especially my parents, say, well, when you're our age, you'll understand.
当年长的人，尤其是我的父母说，好吧，当你到了我们这个年纪，你就会明白的时候，这常常让我发疯。
But there's real truth to it.
但这确实是事实。
There are things you understand at 40 at 50 that you simply are not accessible to at 16 or 21.
有些事情你在 40 岁或 50 岁的时候就能理解，而你在 16 岁或 21 岁的时候根本无法理解。
I think my songwriting is a little bit of a pep talk to myself and whoever cares to pull up a seat around the campfire, that aging is okay and it's good.
我认为我的歌曲创作是对自己的一点鼓舞，无论谁愿意在篝火旁坐下来，衰老都是可以的，这很好。
I'm interested in second half of life wisdom.
我对后半生智慧感兴趣。
My wife, Jordana, who's a psychologist, one thing she'll say her patient sometimes is, what would your 85-year-old self say to you?
我的妻子乔丹娜是一名心理学家，她有时会对她的病人说，你 85 岁的自己会对你说什么？
She says, often it says, don't worry about it, this is not a big deal.
她说，经常说，别担心，这没什么大不了的。
Because when you have that vantage point, your concerns at 35, 45, like they're not going to be as big a deal when you have the larger perspective.
因为当你拥有这样的有利位置时，你在 35 岁、45 岁时的担忧，就像当你拥有更广阔的视野时，它们就不会那么重要了。
I'm curious, how did you meet your wife?
我很好奇，你是怎么认识你老婆的？
Well, I'm going to sound like a real drugy, but we met at a psychedelic sound ceremony.
好吧，我听起来像个真正的吸毒者，但我们是在一个迷幻的声音仪式上认识的。
I was in Nashville recording eulogy and my friend Jacob said, I really want you to come up to upstate New York for the ceremony.
我当时在纳什维尔录制悼词，我的朋友雅各布说，我真的希望你能来纽约州北部参加葬礼。
There's gonna be a lot of people I love there and I went up to upstate New York and there was my wife.
那里会有很多我爱的人，我去了纽约州北部，那里有我的妻子。
I mean, I didn't know at the time, although I had a sense that she was someone that was gonna be in my life, but we met that weekend and we've just kind of been together ever since.
我的意思是，我当时并不知道，虽然我有一种感觉，她会出现在我的生命中，但我们在那个周末见面，从那以后我们就一直在一起了。
You got married in 2024 and I assume you were planning a winter wedding, but not like a blizzard wedding, right?
您于 2024 年结婚，我猜您正在计划一场冬季婚礼，但不像暴风雪婚礼，对吧？
Yes, we were planning a winter wedding, and we got married at this beautiful place called Cedar Lakes Estate, and we said, is it crazy to get married outside?
是的，我们正在计划一场冬季婚礼，我们在这个叫做雪松湖庄园的美丽地方结婚了，我们说，在外面结婚是不是很疯狂？
And they said, no, everyone who gets married in the winter here gets married outside.
他们说，不，这里冬天结婚的人都会在外面结婚。
We do hot chocolate, we'll do hot toddies, it's going to be great.
我们做热巧克力，我们会做热棕榈酒，这会很棒。
And then there was snow forecasted for the weekend, and they said, we can pivot inside if you let us know by 1 p.m.
然后预计周末会下雪，他们说，如果您在下午 1 点之前通知我们，我们可以在里面转转。
But at 1 p.m., there was no snow.
但下午1点，还没有下雪。
So we said, you know what, if it's a light dusting of snow, it'll probably be so beautiful.
所以我们说，你知道吗，如果是薄薄的一层雪，那可能会非常美丽。
Let's just go for it.
让我们努力吧。
At 2.30, it starts snowing and it is not a light dusting.
2.30，开始下雪，而且不是小雪。
Like it is like a proper snowfall dump and it kept coming down.
就像一个真正的降雪场一样，它一直在下。
And by the time we got married at like 4.30 or 5, it was just, but it was beautiful.
当我们在四点三十分或五点左右结婚时，一切都刚刚好，但很美好。
Like the lights, it was magical, but it was also like, the guests were sitting out in the snow for 20 minutes.
就像灯光一样，它很神奇，但也就像，客人们在雪地里坐了 20 分钟。
And then everyone got to go in around this big fire and have hors d'oeuvres with jazz.
然后每个人都可以围着篝火一起享用开胃小菜并欣赏爵士乐。
So people have told us, you know, it's hard to have a wedding that's memorable because they hit a lot of the similar notes and they said, no one who was at your wedding will forget it.
所以人们告诉我们，你知道，很难举办一场令人难忘的婚礼，因为他们有很多相似的音符，他们说，参加你婚礼的人都不会忘记它。
But considering the extraordinary circumstances we met under, we said, well, it was a pretty psychedelic wedding.
但考虑到我们是在特殊的情况下相遇的，我们说，嗯，这是一场相当迷幻的婚礼。
So you described your last song as eternally yoked to your wedding.
所以你形容你的最后一首歌永远与你的婚礼联系在一起。
It's from Fred again and Brian Eno's record that they put out like a year or two ago, two years ago, I don't remember when it came out.
又是 Fred 和 Brian Eno 的唱片，他们在一两年前、两年前发行，我不记得是什么时候发行的。
But this track come on, in particular, my wife and I just fell in love with it.
但这首歌来了，特别是我和我的妻子就爱上了它。
We were listening to it a lot in the run-up to the wedding.
在婚礼前夕，我们经常听这首歌。
And when I hear it, I can't not see images of us and all our friends and family that weekend.
当我听到它时，我无法不看到那个周末我们以及我们所有的朋友和家人的照片。
I didn't get married until now because I was waiting for her.
我直到现在才结婚，因为我在等她。
And it's true that I think there's something, there's our timing and then there's the universe's timing.
确实，我认为有一些东西，那就是我们的时间，然后是宇宙的时间。
And that's kind of how I met your mother theme, right?
这就是我如何遇见你母亲的主题，对吧？
like Ted had an idea about how his life was supposed to go and the universe is like, hold it kid, not so fast.
就像泰德对他的生活应该如何进行有一个想法，而宇宙就像，坚持住，孩子，别那么快。
I wasn't like Ted.
我不像特德。
I wasn't furiously looking around for my wife at all.
我根本没有疯狂地四处寻找我的妻子。
In fact, I was maybe the opposite.
事实上，我可能恰恰相反。
But I was ready and the right person came along at the right time.
但我已经准备好了，正确的人在正确的时间出现了。
And I guess my very last question is, has Ted Mosby taught you anything?
我想我的最后一个问题是，特德·莫斯比教给你什么了吗？
Yeah, I mean, there's many ways to answer that question.
是的，我的意思是，有很多方法可以回答这个问题。
I think globally the show teaches one and me included something about timing.
我认为从全球范围来看，这部剧教会了我和我一些关于时机的知识。
that life is a negotiation with you and the universe, your own desires and the probably better timing that the universe has in mind.
生命是与你和宇宙、你自己的欲望以及宇宙心目中可能更好的时机的谈判。
I think what we're doing here is something like school on some level that there are lessons to be learned and we keep getting the same thing thrown at us until we like learn a lesson and dissolve it.
我认为我们在这里所做的事情在某种程度上就像学校一样，有需要学习的教训，我们不断地收到同样的事情，直到我们喜欢吸取教训并解决它为止。
Ted was something I, it was still irritating me up until recently but something about it has just really softened and I've described him as a younger brother like he's not me and he's sometimes annoying, but he's family.
特德是我的一个人，直到最近它仍然让我恼火，但它的某些东西真的软化了，我把他描述为一个弟弟，就像他不是我一样，他有时很烦人，但他是家人。
So I feel like I can take him along now and there's no problem.
所以我觉得我现在可以带他一起去，没有问题。
I now look back and say, wow, it was a part of something that really influenced like generations of people and how cool is that.
现在我回想起来，会说，哇，这是真正影响了几代人的事情的一部分，这真是太酷了。
Well, Josh, thank you so much for sharing your seven songs and your story.
好吧，乔什，非常感谢你分享你的七首歌和你的故事。
It was great to be here and I love this idea for podcasts.
很高兴来到这里，我喜欢这个播客的想法。
It's challenging to come up with these songs, but it was really fun to walk through all this with you.
创作这些歌曲很有挑战性，但和你一起经历这一切真的很有趣。
So thanks for having me.
所以谢谢你邀请我。
Life in Seven Songs is a production from the San Francisco Standard.
《人生七首歌》是旧金山标准乐队的作品。
If you liked this episode, check out our conversation with the singer-songwriter Rufus Wainwright, who, kind of like Josh, is known for one big thing, but has many more sides of himself to share.
如果您喜欢这一集，请观看我们与创作型歌手鲁弗斯·温赖特 (Rufus Wainwright) 的对话，他有点像乔什 (Josh)，因一件大事而闻名，但他还有更多的一面可以分享。
And if you haven't already, please subscribe and like the show, it makes a big difference for us.
如果您还没有订阅，请订阅并喜欢该节目，这对我们来说意义重大。
Our senior producer is Jasmine Morris, our producers are Michelle Lands, she also mixes the show, and Tessa Kramer.
我们的高级制片人是 Jasmine Morris，我们的制片人是 Michelle Lands，她还负责混音节目，还有 Tessa Kramer。
Our theme music is by Kate Davis and Zubin Hensler, Clark Miller created our show art, and our music consultant is Sarah Tambekian.
我们的主题音乐是 Kate Davis 和 Zubin Hensler 创作的，Clark Miller 创作了我们的表演艺术，我们的音乐顾问是 Sarah Tambekian。
Executive producers are Griffin Gaffney, John Steinberg, and me.
执行制片人是格里芬·加夫尼、约翰·斯坦伯格和我。
As always, you can find this guest's full playlist at sf.news.
与往常一样，您可以在 sf.news 找到这位嘉宾的完整播放列表。
Spotify.
Spotify。
You can listen to the full songs there.
你可以在那里听完整的歌曲。
I'm Sophie Bareman.
我是索菲·巴雷曼。
Thank you for listening and see you next time.
感谢您的聆听，下次再见。